mesmo com altos para esta pvy shaw foi
realmente tem certamente um dia
fantástico eu queria te quero aqui
porque já estiveram no workshop que eu
fiz é este trabalho magnífico das
artistas plásticas e na polícia da
martina de cristiana e ainda da lana e
da carol
o que eu venho estrutura em brincarmos
um pouco sobre a comunicação ea forma de
comunicarmos e as primeiras impressões
que causamos quando falamos com alguém
regra geral nós falamos muito com a
nossa linguagem corporal e com nossa
linguagem não verbal
o fmi é que foi enfim o grande fundador
da bóia grite e o felipe do shea affair
é muito a linguagem corporal o quanto
ela é importante nós passarmos as
primeiras mensagens
as primeiras impressões que nós damos às
pessoas que são os segundos são vitais
neste momento tenho certeza absoluta que
se tivesse agora luz pra plata é é
estariam entre algumas caras do gênio
qual será que ela vai falar
e será que eu vou um vez por serviços
gosto mas nossas pressões e os nossa
linguagem cultural é muito evidente e
faz com que tenhamos ou não reação
enviada das pessoas
eu vou dar um exemplo bem prático há
tempos eu estava no café e estava atrás
de um casal que estavam sentados e vai
um jovem assim bem tem bonito e
dirigiu-se enviado a ela estavam tanto o
casal de imdiato olho pra eu comer
lógica
álvaro é o que aconteceu e
obviamente sentiu o alívio que sentiu
olhado da mulher lógica mt de estrelas
muito bom dia eu posso saber que eu
tendo que sempre que tento que ottomar
eo marido que estava lá ao companheiro
eu estava atrás do companheiro do lado
francês entrou em contato assim
ligeiramente e ela disse eu estava vez
foi entre rui andré e eu obviamente o
marido falando as respostas sempre com
um ar muito desconfiada
o bairro foi por dentro eo marido
começou a ser feito mais baixos verifica
fé escrever e projovem mau serviço
o homem dos seus ter feito um gol do
mixto quisesse ele eo quase enganava
este café não presta pra aliás estão a
piorar
e mais tudo pensar em aumentar o preço
de uma emissão televisiva o que ela
deveria ter feito
lógico o olhar e dizer amor é o que tu
queres beira e virar-se twitter e eu é
que deveria ter feito a conversa voar
minhas coisas ficavam calmas
nós criamos muitas vezes situações deste
gênero e eu vou controlar as pessoas me
verem em cimas a uma equipe que quer que
alguns homens já passaram por isso que é
da roupa moura fez comigo queriam estilo
eu gostava de dizer o seguinte regressar
nós já sabemos o que queremos
quando nós vamos criar um vestido pode
não ser lá gravuristas com a certeza que
nós já temos uma idéia já sabemos acordo
corta
já vimos já tivemos na internet enfim já
fizemos uma pesquisa já contactamos
estilista amiga da estilista já tem
qualquer coisa na manhã
por isso o que é normal é ela sai com um
vestido vermelho com um vestido amarelo
demorou oito lotes mais e eu pensar sim
em si onde exatamente ela e eu viper
gosto dela e diz à mulher que gosta de
elas porque acho que não fica bem o som
olha e quando chega lá fora para
conversar com a amiga já vestiu uma
gorda por isso é nossa linguagem é
corporal é muito importante que nós
transmitimos as pessoas a forma como nós
entendemos as mãos é forma como nós
avançamos
erramos tudo isto faz parte
nós não sorri mas só com o nosso nosso
aves nós temos os lábios mas sorrimos
primeira é a primeira o primeiro sorriso
que nós damos por incrível que pareça
com as sobrancelhas botar do depois é
olhar votar porque se eu fizer um gol o
tarzan assim não é não é verdadeiro é
falso e é a linguagem corporal tem muito
a transmitir nos imenso e é muito
importante no atendimento ao público
é muito importante quando nós estamos à
frente de um serviço quando nós estamos
inclusivamente a trabalhar como
telefonista por exemplo se eu ligar para
o papel de bond e os absurdos é muito
bom dia fala da escola da bela possa
ajudar a mim
esse é o meu coração chapéu pra cá
sistema tem uma pessoa que tem créditos
merece palmas e fantástica pelo vina
comportamento cursos que desafiaria a
vir aqui e ela recusou nuvem mas tem uma
voz maravilhosa lindíssima e sobretudo
tem uma voz em escala que é o que nós
vamos ter nós não podemos falar sempre
com o mesmo tom
porque senão o que vai acontecer em
resolver até porque tenho que fazer as
coisas de mulher é que as pessoas não
entendam que eu estou criou perguntar ou
afirmar auge em agosto muitos têm muito
de ver aqui vai
eu falo com ela agora se olhar e ser ao
júri neves tem muito meu corpo está pra
onde ele acha e quando um preparo seus
cinco imaginemos que o quadro foi na
hora pra mim mesmo assim amanhã temos
informação e oponho pj a desejar
eu já estou aqui nós fazemos instintivo
em todo o atendimento ao público é muito
importante é por isso que eu insisto
muito nisto porque regra geral as suas
que é sem se desse pequeno problema é
bom ter uma boa voz
eu já antes de descer e ir vou deixar
aqui algumas dicas muito rápidas mas é
muito bom
nós temos um bom contato é importante se
eu tiver olharam se o senhor seccionista
isso nos tira um cliente eu tenho que
olhar para esses clientes e não posso
dar computadores e bom dia favor e
temporais e um dia possa ajudar porque
se não fizer isso vai acontecer disse
que não gostaria que o hotel não gosto
de vir aqui o uso de boné que gosta de
diferença seja toda a gente já passou
por isso não é eu queria que eu gostaria
mas porque queria ganhar o gosto é gosto
significa que não é comida é o que eu
fiz e personalizado com as pessoas à
comida conta
mas quanto à forma como nós damos aos
outros como nós conseguimos dar a volta
e conseguimos fazer com que as pessoas
voltem pra nós da mesma forma que nós
damos às pessoas e temos que ter uma voz
bem colocada para que não haja dúvida
sobre o que tem dente
se eu pretendo um café e eu tenho que
dizer por favor podem servir um café de
fé e de um café
eu estou cá para criar algumas unidades
tanto significa que eu tenho que dar
atenção à nossa língua que é lindíssima
de acordo com as estatísticas em 2050
seremos 387 milhões luso falantes o que
é fantástico é lindíssima
nós temos a ter muitas nuances próprios
destaque nos podem encher desde ontem
hoje que não é correto mas nós podemos
mexer na forma como falamos e com
pronunciamos as palavras para isso temos
exercícios que temos que utilizar são
chamados exercícios de aquecimento vocal
eu vou crescer muito rápido a vossa
ajuda para nós a queremos aquilo que a
minha voz adquirimos uma certeza que eu
tenho então aí então o primeiro destes
que é muito fácil e do que eu crianças
fazem a mota do melhor platéia era
impossível
e agora sabe qual é a faixa olharem para
mim com ar mais cheio de espuma o que eu
vou dizer por favor
sabem qual é um dos músicos mais
importantes que nós temos para a nossa
voz à língua e eu preciso ter a
linguagem treinava
então a gente fazer lá lá lá lá
exatamente
é muito importante fazer este exercício
que eu faço entre quem vai tomar
nós podemos querem que o fla
substituição de informática é sobre
estudos o que eu queria nos transmite
sobretudo eu vou pedir aqui ao ew entre
outras coisas meu pornôs o shopping que
eu faço ou na li
vou pedir por favor vamos fazer uma
coisa que eu mandei fazer
obrigada por todo mundo ter jogado eu
pedi a aiea graves até aqui a
organização eu pulei para fazer este
momento porque acho que é isso que é
importante
nós vamos ver se eu der a bottarga eu
percebo botar se eu der a coisa tá na
hora de fazer hoje eu vou receber três
pedras cinco pedras
eu vou receber entre o uaw a piada
eu acho que se nós todos fizemos isso
até mesmo as pessoas que estão a começar
a carreira
às vezes notas quando nós chegamos ao
local uma verdadeira e nós vimos o
pessoal atrapalhada contínuo na máquina
e ela olha para o meu brasil é com
surdos não foi é fui notas não é notas
não faz mal eu tenho tempo tudo mundo
ai como imagina se fosse aqui e ela
acalma
nós não temos muito tempo de observar os
outros porque temos de olhar um
pouquinho pra nós temos que olhar mais
para os outros e receber em troca
exatamente isto que causaram campeã
eu trouxe aqui uma pequena surpresa
quero dizer que até esta é mundial foi
propositadamente para a voz
o nuno é ele ter registado a 12 anos e é
o autor da música a letra é de uma amiga
minha que muitos conhecem é uma
jornalista e outro na lista que é suzana
figueiredo e voz e dores na virilha
ea música tem a ver com o que eu gosto o
que eu quero transmitir que é foi um
sorriso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
é
o um dia que é sorrir era tão sorriso
uti mas no segundo em santo no
instantâneo eu
[Música]
na volta os olhos gostei da tim
enchem e também sorrir
seu sorriso entre as mãos em ti e no
cheiro nem imaginação
só não falei por medo mundo riu vetos
feitos pronto agora posso riste porque
estavam teus lábios tri
se o mundo todo
[Música]
é o
não vou colocar os olhos constância
em 100 creta mais o lê
[Música]
na boca aos olhos gostei assim
nem se inquieta mais sou eu
uns campeã da brigada ganhar
[Aplausos]